when most of us think of natural
resource protection
or wildlife habitat images of vast
expanses of open land
and unbounded water probably come to
mind
but to hundreds of species of animals
and insects
home is where they find it
and many of them would love to find
their home in your backyard
your yard can be rich with life using
the conservation practices you'll see in
the next few minutes
these methods have been used
successfully in the countryside by
america's farmers and ranchers for years
in miniature with some adapting they'll
work in your yard too
and this can be done regardless of the
size of your yard
or if you have a brand new home or an
existing one
like your neighbors in the country
you'll soon discover that by making your
yard more hospitable to nature
you'll add pleasure to your life and
harmony around your home
an easy way to get started on a more
diverse backyard is to plant trees and
shrubs
let your children or those in the
neighborhood help it can be one of those
pleasant
life-long family memories like the day
you helped plant a tree
built a tree house or put up a backyard
swing
trees and shrubs soothe the soul
homeowners and farmers alike plant them
for many of the same reasons
shade energy savings and soil savings
trees and shrubs also help make a more
beautiful landscape and provide space
and habitat for nature's creatures
as a matter of fact private landowners
provide the bulk of the food and habitat
for wildlife in this country
they deserve the credit for making a
home for wildlife
on a whopping 70 percent of the land
in your backyard you can simply change
the scale
and the species of wildlife you want to
attract
look to plant trees and shrubs that
offer fruits
berries nuts and insects for the
wildlife you want
for some small birds such as the warbler
a meal from a tree in your yard just
might be the difference in a successful
migration
native plants and wildflowers are good
ideas too
they lure butterflies hummingbirds and
other wildlife
add a mix of plants to your backyard and
you
and your family may soon see wildlife
you never dreamed of seeing so close to
your home
on the farm sometimes the trees shrub
and grass plantings don't offer enough
food or cover for wildlife
so some farmers plant food plots
especially for wildlife
or put up structures geese and ducks and
birds can use
as protected nests
in your yard the extra food and cover
may come from simple bird feeders
small nest boxes or other bird houses
when it comes to welcoming wildlife and
adding tranquility and beauty
nothing beats water especially ponds and
wetlands
although these conservation projects
require planning
and some maintenance small backyard
ponds
water gardens and wetlands provide many
benefits for birds
butterflies frogs and fish not to
mention
the rewards they give you and your
family
but if you're worried about the extra
effort involved for a pond or water
garden
your water source option can be as
simple and inexpensive
as a bird bath of course
managing and conserving water is just as
important in your backyard
as it is on farms and ranches
it makes sense to save water wherever
you live
reducing the amount of grass you need to
water is one solution
you can design your yard to include more
native grasses
and less lawn grass that you would have
to fertilize
weed and mow
if you need to water your garden
consider installing a more efficient
irrigation system
drip irrigation systems deliver water
directly to the plants
and may soon pay for themselves in water
savings and increase production
conservationists also want to conserve
and recycle waste
and build healthy soil on the farm
animal and plant wastes are returned to
the land to enrich the soil
that can be done in the backyard too by
composting
composting is easy it turns lawn debris
and fruit and vegetable waste
such as melon rinds and banana peels
into organic matter
that makes high quality soil
here are a few more conservation
techniques you can use to improve your
yard
and the environment like your neighbors
in the country
you'll want to test your soil before you
add nutrients or fertilizers
and put them only where you need them
and in just the right amounts this not
only makes for healthier plant life
but it also saves money and helps keep
our water
clean and when it comes to pesticides
the best conservation advice is
prevention
when you can plant disease and pest
resistant species
and introduce beneficial insects such as
the ladybug
and praying mantis
when you need pesticides pinpoint the
problem
and read and follow the label
instructions carefully
mulching is a good way to protect your
soil from erosion
cut down on weed growth and conserve
soil moisture
you can recycle the materials in your
own yard as mulch
one last conservation technique is
terracing
although terracing might involve more
initial expense and effort
it's an excellent way to increase
gardening areas and to reduce soil
erosion
plus it can add beautiful architectural
touches
to yards and gardens
conservation whether in the countryside
or in the city
starts with a personal commitment
by farmers and ranchers who keep soil
productive and water clean
and share their big yards with fish and
wildlife
by neighbors who come together to
develop their parks as a place of
harmony and diversity
and by homeowners who provide a
sanctuary in their backyards
for butterflies and birds
together we can make our homes our
neighborhoods
and our earth a friendlier better place
to live
one yard at a time
when you look at all the different
plants and what we have here
the maintenance has been surprisingly
simple
but now that we have this yard we're out
in the yard more
on the weekends not just to cut the
grass not just for maintenance but to
really enjoy it
and there's a certain pride and you know
just
i think anybody would feel that way and
we enjoy having
friends come over because they enjoy the
yard
but you know i wish i had done it a long
time ago
i'd have been more involved in the yard
because i didn't realize how much
enjoyment
there are a lot of rewards they really
are
once you get into it it's a lot of fun
it really
you